this is exciting it's been a while but
we're going to do another
episode of clueless gamer
special guest today mr jb smoove
i love this now you were a very good
video game player are you not mr jb's
move
i'll tell you something i've been
playing video games forever conan
we're going to play a game called bio
mutant let's get our good friend to
explain
our our gaming aficionado mr aaron blair
we call him blai blay how are you hey
i'm doing good hey
hey what's up thank you for being uh
socially distant yes uh i prefer you
socially distant
um no just because it's safe for kovid
and uh
you can annoy me at times but you're a
good guy and you really know your video
games tell us about biomutant all right
biomutant is very
exciting we play a lot of games where
there's like the post apocalypse
every game we play is the
post-apocalyptic
apocalypse every time we start a game
he's i say what happens and he says all
you have to know
is the world blew up a thousand years
ago and now
everything's blown to ships and you've
got a glorgar gun but there are glaxons
and bling blings and blow blows
biomutants different
it's different because this is the post
post-apocalypse
wow humanity has died out and so these
these animals have mutated because of
all of our garbage
and and the earth has kind of come back
and the tree of life has
has brought life back to the earth and
so we're going to play uh a mutant
a mammalian warrior oh
hey look at you i like that outfit
encode your dna
oh okay so we're now implanting our dna
into a raccoon
well we're we're we're designing what
i'm asking we want our team
we're not implanted when i was in summer
camp i was caught putting my dna in a
raccoon
no i didn't allow me back we also have
conan if you want we had graphics make
up what you and jb would look like
as biomutants this is huge
now see that guy is perfect and then
check this guy out huh yo that's you all
day
oh i love the teeth wait a minute yours
is so much cooler than mine
yeah why did they give me those teeth
and a beady eye
do i have a bdi in real life kind of you
got two two of them oh for god's sake
jb wow you're very comfortable
crossroads choosing a path in life is
that fork in the road where you
love a fork on the road this is so
powerful can't believe you'd choose that
thing over me
so far it's a lot of talking you know a
reminder that we're at the mercy of
nature
and the one that preys on others does
this guy ever
shut up oh oh oh you want some of this
oh cut the balls off you're chopping
they're looking [ __ ] choosy good
hey look at that roll you got a good
roll chibi you are very good
yup whoa see when somebody got long arms
like boxing
i think mike tyson survived all those
fights man
all he everyone he thought was taller
than him oh i thought you meant he had a
sword and
he saw the crotch inside on him
i'm not playing conan look at that baby
jb
it never goes like this when i'm at the
controls it's a mess
you're a maestro you want me to try it
corner come on man what do i do i don't
look good
oh move around now go get get inside him
he can't i don't want to get inside him
get rid of these little guys first get
rid of him
pop out pop pop get him out of here get
him out of there let him have it
come out fight fight fight get him get
him out of there whoa
yes yes conan press a press a a
yes conan yes conan yes yes
that's conan you got this whoa conan
you're boogieing now baby this is the
best video gaming i've ever done that's
why i guess that's why you farewell
cause why again
you know you're the best coach i've ever
had no one else explains it as well as
you do you know why cause i want you to
win
you you root for me not against you i
ruled you the win
no one's ever encouraged me this much
before go over there you got me
believing i can do it
here's someone who takes each day as it
comes
what happened to this game what is
better than a baby pool
you know what what is this this game
suddenly turned into something stupid
it seems you forgot something that's the
mother mama
look who's the bag
[Laughter]
who's this guy no that's your dad popsy
what's up popsy all right so now we're
gonna go outside so our mom created
a fighting style called wong fu she's
going to teach us
so mom is out up the stairs training us
to be a good fighter in the post
apocalypse dad
is doing uh he's sewing that's correct
he doesn't seem to leave that room he's
depressed you know what that is that's a
sign of depression
this is a loveless marriage that man has
given up
uh-oh your luma says you can make it if
you believe in it
where she goes you go blood is thicker
than water
swim to your mops go to my mom oh look
oh oh oh oh my mom
i'm going down you got my mom you want
to save her mom mom
no oh you tried though ah
look he's like ah i tried death is not
to be feared by what he did
his mom he's like ah i tried a part of
her
will live on in you well she could live
if you went back down for her oh no
[ __ ] jb you just got into a large
machine that you can operate and now
you're ready to fight another creature i
think
this is what the 405 freeway will look
like in two years
we don't get new infrastructure so this
is the first uh
world eater who's eating see the root of
the
the tree of life so we got to stop them
i'm gonna try to reason when i'm first
jumbo puff is kicking it up enough okay
sounds like a snack
this isn't so bad you can do a lot of
damage in there
oh no better move up is that right look
at you all pooped out
from this point
see that you did it you went into his
stomach he did very sampling stamping on
red fox he said oh look at the big one
yeah so all right so what do you guys
think biomutin what do you guys think i
think this game would be perfect
little less talking and when i say a
little less than a lot less
it was a game that went way too long
and seemed to have no point where a boy
started to save his mother and then said
ah screw it
and let her drown where a lot of
pointless meandering somehow was
supposed to mean something
in a world nobody cared about
a father sowed in a dark room depressed
while a mother seemed to do most
everything and yet the game went on
and on god this talking has got to stop
and the narrator kept talking and
talking
this is and saying things like
be good to yourself oh my god
and a smile is just a frown turn upside
down
crap you've been hearing since you were
a kid and you should add to this
um the crack of someone's ass
turns sideways it is it's a hoagie
a hoagie sandwich
all right